hast du eine bauten nach gehört hast du
dir überhaupt das video anschaut hast du
überhaupt eine sekunde daran
verschwendet mal zuzuhören
dann hättest du das nicht geschrieben
hallo leute ist wieder einmal waren und
bekommt zu 35 grad in berlin und eine
affenhitze in meiner wohnung heute war
so ein tag an dem ich viel gemacht habe
unter anderem duschen nicht dass es
jetzt irgendwas besonderes ist aber
vielleicht sieht man das ja an meinen
haaren ich mir keine kommentare lesen
vanessa deine haare russ los sie sind
einfach bisschen muffig kennt das noch
jemand von euch wenn ihr eure haare
frisch gewaschen habe und es so ein
sommerwetter ist bei mir werden die
nicht so curly sommer wählen um ingo
just bei mir werden dieses chaos an dass
es jetzt ein bisschen geblufft ist aber
einiges nur warm es ist nur so verdammt
war
aber das soll uns nicht stören heute
habt ihr das gesehen
das ist das problem ein leder und
gelebte mal so ein bisschen dran
heute habe ich sushi und das ist ein
ganz spezielles so schien es habe ich
bestellt ich habe es immer gesehen und
wollte bestellen
es war mir ein bisschen zu teuer immer
und dann habe ich gedacht heute ist der
tag heute wäre ich mir das sie bestellen
und zwar es ist so ein was berlin
zwischen berliner und green und
irgendwas aubergine grüner spargel gurke
das ding es auch irgendwie angebrannt
und das lag mit dabei und it to me
reseau delicious 300 redet ja und auf
jeden fall eine sommer rolle die
beständig immer mit kurkuma reis avocado
koriander salat und dazu gibt es eine
braune soße zu trinken
very important to stay redet
keine ahnung warum ich mein englisch zum
wechsel irgendwie habe ich das jetzt so
das klingt so bescheuert wenn man
deutsch spricht und immer so englische
sagt also crazy und wird benutze ich
sehr oft sind sie drucken und zu
betreiben
so einfach geht s also quasi mit benutze
ich sehr auf aber und wissen aber erst
aufgefallen als ich mit meiner besten
freundin ausgesprochen habe denn
irgendwann ja weil sie das halt nicht
sagt und habe ich gemerkt wie oft das
ist so wie hat um ein grad ist so crazy
was passiert ist das würde ich mir gerne
wieder umgewöhnen ich weiß nicht
irgendwas ist eine sprache die dies
komme ich wisst ihr was ich meine
kapiert auch so paar worte die ihr sagt
die eigentlich komisch sind schreibt sie
machen die kommentare
[Musik]
mein gott wasser und zitronen es gibt
nichts besseres für den sommer
da von einem dreh für sonntag für
donnerstag heute sonntag habe ich noch
mit leder damit könnt ihr euch super
getränke zu hause machen kaufte nicht
diese komischen eistees wo ihr mann
nicht wisst was da an
konservierungsstoffen und so drin ist
die kann ich zum beispiel auch überhaupt
nicht vertragen immer wenn ich so ein
eistee trinke ich immer kopfschmerzen
kennt das einer von euch heißt dass
irgendwas ich habe schon irgendwas
irgendwem irgendwas was da drin ist habe
ich eine energie bestimmt so jetzt wird
es noch besser dass auch ein geräusch
des sommers oder eiswürfel im glas ist
man so ungerührt man kann im sommer auch
nicht genug eiswürfel haben
naumburg weg schon wie reichert schon
wieder englisch gesprochen was ist mit
mir los ich muss mich erst mal gemütlich
hinsetzen sieht man in den letzten
wochen haben viele gesagt das sieht doch
irgendwie komisch aus wenn du so mack
das knie rausguckt oder könnt ihr euch
man an meinen nacht das knie sieht
seltsam aus kann man mich zwingen das
ist unten
beim letzten mal habe ich viele leute
gesehen die er geschrieben haben wie
wertig doch da sitze ich ja des penis
was muss ich noch mal zu anfang sagen
ich fange ich an zu essen keine sonne
deswegen hast früher habe bei meiner
familie
da gab es nicht so ganz diese
tischmanieren also ellbogen auf dem
tisch war okay sitzen na klar da konnten
wir jetzt endlich auf dem stuhl liegen
aber ich durfte hat mich irgendwie so
seitlich hinlegen oder setzen und im
schneidersitz auf dem stuhl sitzen
meine mutter ist erzieherin und die
wahrheit schon immer jetzt kommt mal
wieder mit pädagogen eltern und so was
ne dass die kinder mal verdorben sind
meine eltern mutter satiren und sie war
schon immer auch im kindergarten oder wo
sie gearbeitet hat immer so die
entspannteste es gab ja so regel im
kindergarten dass man die position die
man sich auf legt man die auch essen
muss er ist ja auch eine gute regel weil
du musst ja lernen die sachen
einzuteilen oder teilweise krieg sie
eine portion und muss die portion
genauso essen wie du sie bekommst und
meine mutter hat dann immer so wenn
dieses jahr vergessen lassen so halt
genetisch gekriegt und mutter hat dann
nicht mehr weil das heißt kinder
portionen sind hat die letzten sachen im
mund getan gegessen und dann hat das
kind nach durchgekriegt ja und so war
das halt auch bei uns zu hause und sagt
zu hause kann man sich so ein bisschen
vorstellen wie die villa kunterbunt es
gab schon regeln die so die konnte man
nicht unterbrechen aber eigentlich war
es villa kunterbunt so und bevor ich
jetzt anfangen zu essen
es tut mir leid einmal werbung denn am
freitag ist auf dem was das geht kanal
ein video mit mir und mirela online
gegangen was wirklich sehr sehr witzig
geworden ist also gesprächen darüber was
junge leute also menschen unserem alter
nichts sagen würden
und ja es ist so ein eigenes format was
es schon eigentlich gibt aber es ist
mega lustig geworden weil wir halt auch
während des drehs immer so witzige ideen
bekommen haben
das war seit langem mal wieder dass
michael und ich so komme die zusammen
gemacht haben
das war einfach ein super dreh ich hoffe
ihr schaut euch das video an abonniert
den kanal unbedingt gefällt da kommt
regelmäßig so was was uns junge leute
interessiert also ich finde es echt ein
kleiner kanals hat mega spaß gemacht da
gewesen zu sein und mit mir da zu drehen
und jetzt geht weiter mit dem u bahn
okay leute lieben zurück wurde was zu
essen der podcast schrägstrich mit bahn
geht los das der kommune drauf
mein gott kein wunder dass so teuer ist
[Musik]
das warten hat sich gelohnt
kelly hat eine nasa mehr video
hochgeladen und da ist mir erst mal
aufgefallen was für eine gute lehrstelle
stimme kelly hat ich habe das so
geschaut und dachte erst mal so höhe
wird sich sie macht also mehr und
irgendwann habe ich gemeint ist echt
entspannt wurde bei ihre stimme sehr
angenehm ist also falsch
hier das video noch nicht gesehen hab
ich gar keine werbung kock das macht
ich bin nicht wesentlich schmatzer ich
habe mich jetzt jemand auf die person
behauptet dass deutsch mathe und ich
weiß es ein bisschen freundin kämpft
seit jahren mit mir weißt du deutsch
mathe aber wegen macht mich dass die
geborenen wangerin ich halte mich aber
zurück keine sorge es tut mir leid mit
meinen haaren
ich lass das jetzt so und falls jetzt
voll auf deinem bett liegt und dieses
video schaust mache es auch laut und
bäumen dein zimmer auf oder deine
wohnung oder ein haus und garten was
deine eltern gegeben haben wie ein hund
weil du wärst war schlecht jetzt gibt es
einmal sommer rolle
das ist eine sommer wolle eine
sonderrolle ist in reispapier eingepackt
hat reis oder nudeln drin und gemüse und
avocado und so ein quatsch
meistens auch tofu oder huhn das kind
hochformat und thun nicht esse ohne bei
ist so schön in diese braune soße rippen
und ich nicht was es ist
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt in 4k auf hat sich das
aufgefallen ist es ist niemandem
aufgefallen verdammt der schweiz
ich hab jetzt schon so viele videos in
4k hochgeladen
keiner sagt mal vanessa cool nach sogar
hofft nimmst hallo leute
das geht schon viel aufwendiger in vier
kauf zu nehmen schreibt das jetzt in die
kommentare wenn ihr bis jetzt dran
geblieben seid danke vanessa das den
verkauf nimmt dann kann ich es sogar auf
meinem smartphone wie vor und gucken
ich schaue ja in letzter zeit also ich
hab mir so fernseher gekauft
letztes jahr oder so der dieses marty
hat mit netflix taste ganz wichtig oder
netflix taste geht nix und seitdem
schaue ich die meisten videos eigentlich
ja auf dem fernseher und das ist so
lustig weil man kann ja sehen auf
flächen etwa welchen geräten meine
zuschauer denn die videos schauen dass
meistens natürlich handy bei jeder
heutzutage ein handy und damit das macht
aber ich schaue nur auf dem fernsehsofa
blogs personell stark galt fiel auf dem
world wide bonusmaterial ist auch ein
video mit mir an eingegangen nun mal so
habt ihr das auch also gucken welche
leute von euch auch viel auf dem
fernseher was ist das ich habe keine
ahnung aber es ist verdammt lecker mit
so richtig richtig hunger zu essen es
gibt nichts besseres es tut mir leid
falls jemand dadurch die junge art von
euch kommen zu vermuten ja vermuten
ich will dass meine neuen typ golf wird
und nicht nur youtube
ich habe darüber nachgedacht
ich glaube ich mache ihnen einen antrag
weil ich finde doch nichts besseres als
paten und wir haben den gleichen beruf
das schweißt zusammen
dann können wir über youtube reden und
wenn es bei mir nicht mehr läuft dann
lebe ich einfach von paletten einnahmen
ich glaube dann höre ich ganz
aufzuarbeiten und lebe von klotens geld
ich halt nicht so viel von emanzipation
ich finde das ist ja
luca war nicht mal mehr ironisch
irgendwas sagen weil dann sonst denkt
also ich liebe panten das ist nicht
ironisch aber ich will obwohl ganz
ehrlich wenn ich mit booten verheiratet
bin dann mal ab und wenn ich mir paar
lücken verheiratet wäre würde ich
wirklich nur noch videos machen wenn ich
morgens aufwache und denke oh hi denn
wenn ich ein video drehen ich will
unbedingt das machen
natürlich ist das jetzt auch so dass ich
dort immer auf die videos habe ich würde
das nicht machen wenn ich kein bock
hätte aber ich hab halt auch tage oder
wochen wo ich einfach nicht so gerne für
kamera wird wie an anderen tagen
und wenn man halt diesen druck nicht
hätte dass man das hochladen muss weil
dein ehemann paletten ist und einfach
verdienen die let's play sowie einfach
die macht schon wieder videos sie werden
schon viel verdienen und erster autor
also ich sag mal hauptgewinn pannen im
einfachen kuchen backen
dann wird er irgendwann fängt aber
[Musik]
glücklich also ich da mithalten wer mit
mir glücklich halten was du das siehst
ich liebe dich bitte hatte nicht und da
sie nur noch videos machen muss kann
wenn ich wirklich will und dann mache
ich ein restaurant auf den verkauf nur
noch kuchen backe den ganzen tag buchen
okay das wird schon zum halt erstmals
konnte mich natürlich heiraten und
danach nicht so schnell los ist lieber
dieser wunderschöne sommer rolle
genießen
oh mein gott die soße ist der hammer war
nicht wirklich der hammer ich glaube es
ist erdnuss oder irgendeine andere muss
irgendwie sowas
[Musik]
ich kenne das video sehr
einmal sommer lasst uns darüber reden wo
ich wollte euch noch was erzählen ich
habe ja instagram gelöscht und alle
lieder installiert und ich habe mich
dazu entschieden also ich will nicht
mehr so viel klassische werbung auf
instagram machen also ja ich hatte euch
das in zwei videos gesamt auf jeden fall
ist in letzter zeit auch wenig bei mir
allein gegangen oder beziehungsweise
bisschen weniger weil das ist jetzt ein
ich mache sonst ein bis zwei videos die
woche jetzt zwar nie halt weg zu solchen
money video das hat auch ein richtiges
videos hat hat vor eine lange gedauert
das ist ewig lang geworden
das ist super geil geworden ich finde
dieses magie diese challenge das hat so
spaß gemacht diese teile kitchen zu
machen und da zum wochenmarkt zu fahren
und das alles vor mitzunehmen und es hat
mich ein bisschen erinnert wieso shane
dawson blogs natürlich nicht so witzig
washington es schön draußen aber es hat
so einen touch gehabt und das habe ich
wirklich gut und jetzt
habe ich die letzten tage viel an einem
projekt gearbeitet was auf instagram
online kommen wird aber ich verrate
schon mal so über die wm-zeit verkommen
mancher stories die glaube ich sehr cool
werden also falls sie mir nicht auf
instagram folgt dann kommen wir zum
projekt wo ich sage geil predigt bock
drauf das wird spaß machen auch es zu
filmen und so und ist total des neues
und ist total was weiß ich noch nicht
gemacht habe und ich bin total total
total total ich bin voll aufgeregt bei
ist es mal bei youtube alltag ist halt
sehr eintönig auch wenn es der tollste
job der welt es ist irgendwann eintönig
wenn du halt das gleiche maß und
natürlich michael dreher schneider
schneider ich mach mal ein anderes video
an der relius dazu kam mir gleich aber
macht heilt wenn man das gleiche so und
das ist jetzt so ein projekt wo ich sage
dann bin ich auch also da bin ich auch
sehr aufgeregt und fühle mich ein
bisschen gestresst weil das halt
komplett raus ist und man ist ja so
gerne in seiner ich sag mal vom 14
und das ist komplett raus ist der kampf
um das ist werbung auf youtube
instagram wo ich ein bisschen schiss ab
weil ich weiß die meisten von euch sind
super die meisten von euch sind wirklich
so tolle menschen und das habe ich gar
nicht so dass ich liebe euch alle
ich weiß dass ich nicht so komplett die
masse jetzt ansprechen oder besonders so
ein video jetzt und mutter ein video das
ist nicht so massen klick bewegen wo
alle draufklicken unbedingt wissen
wollen
wie ist vanessa es ist so ein video wo
halt die leute die mich gern haben und
mir gerne zu haben der mir sagt van das
sind halt auch die leute während denen
ich auch gerne zuhören würde oder die
zuschauer die ich die mich auf der
straße ansprechen
das sind immer leute wo ich sage ja also
für mich komplett cool so habe ich habe
ich also kein vorurteil keinen gedanken
der saucen das würde personen das ist
immer wo ich mir denke ja genau für
solche leute wie dich oder genau so eine
zuschauer möchte ich haben und habe ich
und ich wollte ich finde jetzt immer
wieder den faden
das gelingt nicht immer auf jeden fall
wollt ihr euch sagen dass ich weiß dass
die leute geben wird sagen werden jetzt
macht wieder über die wm-zeit wir haben
auf instagram obwohl wie gesagt hat wie
instagram gelöscht hat und wegen der
ganzen werbung und das waren sie doch
alles so tacke und jetzt macht sie es
trotzdem
und ich weiß dass es nur ein paar mal
sind die so denken die einen nichts
können wir das nicht nur ein werbe oder
ich weiß aber dass der großteil mir
sachen könnt und wenn dass sie das gut
finden oder irgendwas sie dadurch wird
dann sagen wie eine angebrachte kritik
aber nicht halt die werbung auf milch
nach und macht windows genau so stelle
ich mir die leute vor genau so stelle
ich mir die leute vor wenn ich so ein
blödes hate kommentare so oder so ein
kommentar wo ich denke so erschlossene
bauten nach gehört hast du dir überhaupt
das video anschaut hast du überhaupt
eine sekunde daran verschwendet mal
zuzuhören
dann hättest du das nicht geschrieben
aber es waren die meisten leute nicht
diese blöden kommentare schreiben sie
einfach nur verletzten selbst casey nein
das war nicht so krass bis heute oder
gestern los und video von ihm gesehen wo
casement es selber sagt dass vorhält
kommentare oder sogar böse kommentare
ihnen auch verletzten und das ist mir
aufgefallen ist es so scheiß egal wie
viele follower fast wie groß du bist am
ende fällt wenn dir jemand etwas böses
schreibt bist du verletzt ende
und wenn es jetzt jemanden anfeuert mir
was böses runter zu schreiben macht es
doch ich weiß am ende des tages nicht so
meint ist was verletzt einheit danke
[Musik]
das projekt kommt schon sehr lange her
dass ich das letzte mal gemacht habe ich
war ja 10
mein bruder war bei der reha vielleicht
erinnert ihr euch das was ich dazu jetzt
nichts zu sagen wir das was ich ihm
dafür zeit in polen und das war so cool
weil meine mutter hat mir immer wieder
videos geschickt und so und er hat das
so fortschritte gemacht also immer noch
natürlich nicht diese hoffnung dass
irgendwann alles wieder normal ist die
habe ich nicht mehr wo ich ehrlich sagen
aber so alleine wenn ich sehe wie er da
so ein flur lang läuft kohl im rollstuhl
sitzt und dann läuft er das im frühjahr
mit dem therapeuten halt so vor ihm und
er läuft denn da er sieht man ein
bisschen aus wie ihr kennt ihr noch
augsburger puppenkiste
so sieht mein bruder aus dann läuft
einfach
und der weiß das und es ist jetzt glaube
ich bald vorbei und dann fahren wir in
den urlaub
die türkei hat meine mutter ganz günstig
geschossen
[Musik]
das nicht schön
das wollte ich euch sagen weil ich ja
erzählt dass er da ist es hat mir sehr
gut gefallen aber erst noch ich auch
froh dass jetzt wieder nach hause kann
wenn das ist sehr viel sport gemacht
people
es ist ehrlich ist
[Musik]
passt aber auch perfekt
bevor ich aufhöre zu essen gibt es noch
einen abschlüssen anschließenden satt
gesehen was wichtiges was ich sagen
wollte ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
ich hoffe ihr sommerstorf sommerloch ich
glaube dass er mal beginnen wir einen 20
im juni glaubt dann geht auch sommer
doch los ich habe nichts vorbereitet
ich freue mich einfach drauf dass es
wieder losgeht und ich freue mich
tatsächlich sehr auf sommerloch weil das
ist immer wieder auch so diese
sommerpause die ich mir auch selber gebe
um so ein bisschen halt andere videos
mache das leben ist schön heute
ich sage euch gutes sushi tolle viel
spaß bei der arbeit
500.000 abonnenten für 28 oder wenn sie
das video seht wahrscheinlich 535 oder
auch nicht sommer das ist
es ist einfach super und ich hoffe
wirklich dass es euch auch gut geht
ich werde noch ein video drehen warum es
mir besonders gut geht
es gibt nämlich einen story ein video
was sich aufnehmen möchte
ganz klassisch ohne dass ich mich über
diese idee oder so was ich mache es gibt
einen stockheim video was auch die
möchte was erzählt warum es mir die
letzten eineinhalb jahre nicht so gut
ging habe ich euch nur was vorgemacht
ist das alles hier eine lüge es ist eine
story von mir also mir ging es gut aber
auch nicht aber auch schon und
alles aufgewertet wenn du noch das hier
dran geblieben ist
danke das ist so liegt vor mir ich hoffe
dass wir uns mal auf der straße sehen
und wenn foto zusammen machen können ich
umarme dich gerne ich habe all meine
zuschauer selbst wenn sie mich nicht
fragen dann verließ sie anzumachen es
ist immer sehr gut und wenn ihr das
video gefallen hat dann unterstütze mich
mit einem daumen nach oben
und wenn du kein neues video verpassen
will jetzt locker aktivieren und wenn du
vielleicht noch kommentar hinterlässt
ist sie gefallen hat was ich vielleicht
das nicht mal essen soll dann esse ich
das vielleicht das nächste mal
ich habe jetzt diese kleine herdplatten
den ofen also wie der ofen werde ich
mich benutzt aber ich glaube ich mache
das nächste mal so ein ruck bank
wahrscheinlich werde es nicht tun aber
ich will es tun mit der herdplatte dass
ich quasi hier kochen so schön und dann
wisst ihr das egal
ich habe ich ganz gut bis dann